there's also been moments where i've
looked back on videos
and i realized that these don't
represent me anymore and
they're hurtful to other people david
dobrik has been dropped from
several partnerships in the wake of
sexual misconduct allegations
surrounding the vlog squad e.t has
reached out to dobrik for comment
consent is something that's super super
important to me whether i'm shooting
with a friend
or shooting with a stranger i always
make sure that whatever the video i'm
putting out i have
the approval from that person i also
acknowledge that
those times where a person can change
their mind and they
decide that they no longer want to be
associated and no longer want to be in
the video
that i'm putting up and then i'll take
the video down
in a video posted last tuesday dobrick
apologized to joseph
seth francois following his allegation
of sexual misconduct in a 2017
prank video i wanted to come out and say
something to
clear my own conscience from the things
that i was doing
and i was allowing to happen within
david's content
francois says he was tricked into
kissing jason nash
this is also david's content and he's
the one that's coming up with the ideas
and he's the one that has the power and
is asking people
to participate in certain things and
there is a lot of pressure
you know when you're in the room and
you're the only person of your skin
color or your culture
and you're trying to represent in the
right way and you're constantly being
pressured
to do things that you might know are
wrong and you are uncomfortable with
with the set situation i'm sorry to seth
because
i like i said i i just want to make
videos
where everybody in it you know whether
you're participating or watching
is enjoying and having a good time and i
miss the mark with that one
and i'm really sorry i truly truly am
dobrick also said in the video that he's
no longer friends with dominicus
zeglitis aka dirty dom
and doesn't stand for any kind of
misconduct
after a woman came forward alleging
zeglitis sexually assaulted her when she
came to the blog squad's home
to film a video in 2018. the main reason
i'm making this video
is to hold accountability for my actions
and you know not only not only apologize
to you know people that i worked with
that i may have disrespected
but also to other people that were
affected by my actions
i've been really disappointed by some of
my friends and for that reason
i've separated from a lot of them e.t
has reached out to zeg leitis for
comment
in a statement to et on sunday a
spokesperson for doordash said the
company has
terminated its partnership with dobrik
quote this horrific misconduct is
incongruous with doordash's values and
does not represent the communities we
strive to create
our thoughts are with all those impacted
meanwhile an ea spokesperson tells et
that they are aware of the allegations
against dobrik
adding that they haven't worked with him
since april 2020
and have no plans to in the future quote
we expect
any influencer or celebrity talent we
work with to conduct themselves in a
manner that is consistent with ea's
values and
policies a spokesperson for hellofresh
echoed that sentiment telling et quote
we can confirm that we are no longer
working with david dobrik or any member
of the vlog squad
and do not have any plans to work with
them again in the future
dollar shave club confirmed to business
insider that they made the decision to
end their working relationship with
dobrik
while seek geek told the outlet they are
reviewing their partnership with the
youtube star
i think with any video i make my main
purpose
is to make people happy and and inspire
people and i'm sorry if i've let you
down
and things like that won't happen again
and i learn from my mistakes
and i also believe that actions speak a
lot louder than words